Welcome to The Beginner's Guide for
armored Core 6. by the end of this video
you'll understand what it means to play
Armored Core at a higher level you'll be
faster at the controls you'll know how
to put together a powerful AC and you'll
be able to quickly read and adapt to any
situation feel free to skip ahead to a
section that you're more interested in
but for now let's get started at the
beginning
first let's get to grips with the
controls this guide will assume that
you're using the default type a control
assignment with a controller but mouse
and keyboard Can Be an Effective means
of control as well if you're playing on
PC be sure to open up the settings menu
and scroll down to input device settings
where you can ensure that your button
prompts are being properly displayed for
the input you're using and while you're
here in the settings I also like to go
into the camera settings and turn camera
speed to 10. that's because turning
quickly to face enemies is very
important in armored Core as you'll soon
learn so you've just crash landed on
Rubicon and your AC has taken damage its
AP which stands for armor points can be
viewed here to instantly repair your AC
press up on the d-pad this consumes a
repair charge seen here which instantly
heals your AC for a flat 4000 AP the bar
underneath shows the delay before you
can repair your AC again and it's
important to note that you can't repair
your AC while firing your Weaponry be
sure to keep your AC topped up on health
especially if you think an enemy is
capable of extremely damaging attacks
which many of them are if you think
enemies might be nearby you can press
down on the d-pad to scan your
environment again the bar below shows
how often you can use this so there's no
enemies nearby but if there was you
could fire at them with any of one of
your four weapon slots right now we're
equipped with an assault rifle in our
right hand a missile launcher on our
right shoulder and a laser blade on our
left arm your back triggers activate
your left and right arm weapons and your
front bumpers activate your left and
right back weapons note how your total
ammunition depletes in the bottom right
of the screen and how your current
magazine capacity is affected here
around your lock-on
let's get moving so when at a standstill
your Glide boosters are disengaged and
you can walk however you'll often want
to press Circle or B to manually engage
your boosters while grounded as that is
a superior form of movement especially
in combat note that these Glide boosters
automatically toggle on when you quick
boost as well the indicator for Glide
boosting is seen here we'll need to
ascend to reach our objective marker
which is shown here pressing X or a
while grounded will cause you to jump
with your leg part and after that jump
holding X or a will cause you to ascend
with your boosters ascending requires
energy which is being depleted here
energy consumption is paused while
descending and your energy recovers
really rapidly while you're grounded if
you fully deplete your energy bar it
will go red and energy will not recover
for a short duration so you should
generally try to avoid fully depleting
your energy bar if
In the Heat of combat keep an ear out
for warning sounds as well the warning
for loss of energy is just one sound
that can give you crucial information
now let's fight some enemies in this
game lock-on is automatic when you're in
range and the enemy closest to the
center of your screen will be locked
onto by moving the camera you can Target
other enemies by aligning them more
closely with the center of your screen
this method of targeting is particularly
useful when taking out multiple enemies
as you might want some to have priority
over others our assault rifle is on our
right arm so we fire it with R2 and take
them out
however in many cases you might prefer a
more automatic hard lock and for this
you can enable Target assist by pressing
R3 in this mode four crescents appear
here and now when an enemy is in your
sights you'll be hard locked onto them
in this state you're tracking accuracy
is slightly reduced so your shots might
not hit your target as effectively as if
you didn't have Target assist on however
this way your enemy is kept in your
sights at all times and you don't need
to touch the thumbstick at all really
this is particularly useful when you're
fighting against a single difficult
enemy especially if that enemy has
dangerous attacks that require you to
focus on dodging and flight instead one
thing to note in the center of our
lock-on is this yellow Crescent that's
your missile marker and the number
represents how many missiles are
chambered and ready to be fired at this
enemy only try and fire your missiles
once the yellow bar has fully loaded
like this when the number appears you're
fully locked up and while you can fire
the missiles before this they won't
track very well at all our missiles are
attached to our right back so the marker
appears in the top right and we can
press R1 to fire them but if you're
against multiple enemies you might not
want to fire all your missiles at just
one enemy instead what you can do is
hold down the fire button like this this
will acquire a multi-lock and split your
missiles evenly to All Enemies within
your field of view lastly our starter
build is equipped with a laser blade on
its left hand this means we can tap L2
to swing it and it will boost us towards
any locked enemy as far as our energy
will allow all melee weapons can have
their input held for a charge attack and
this one in particular can be swung
twice if L2 is pressed in succession
after attacks the blade also overheats
meaning it can't be used for a short
period of time
for every encounter you should be
finding a way to maximize efficient use
of every weapon you have equipped with
this build we use multi-lock missiles to
initiate we fire the assault rifle when
we're in range and we use the blade
whenever we spy a safe opening
so we've just finished a fight and our
assault rifle is low on ammo many
weapons only reload automatically when
their magazines are empty so you should
make a habit of manually reloading to
ensure that you're topped up between
fights manual reloads can be done by
holding down triangle or Y and tapping
the fire button for the weapon that you
want to reload let's head down to the
city
this is called an assault boost you
perform this by pressing L3 and it
propels you towards wherever you're
aiming pull back on the left stick to
cancel the assault boost like this or
tap the Ascend button X or a to cancel
your Boost while maintaining your
forward momentum like this
assault boosts are by far the most
efficient way to move around the map
however where this ability really excels
is in combat
assault boost is just an excellent tool
for closing the Gap towards enemies
and if you have the energy to spare you
can even Dodge left or right during it
by tapping the left analog stick like
this
what makes assault boost truly powerful
is that you can attack as you assault
boost and many attacks done during this
time deal increased impact damage
meaning they'll be more effective at
breaking enemy guards what's more impact
you receive during this time is also
lessened meaning you can assault boost
into many enemies with Reckless abandon
so let's show this off against the next
two enemies who have shields by
combining our assault boost with a blade
attack we can absolutely obliterate them
but let's keep the second one alive for
now see the two meters above the enemy
this one shows the enemy's health and
the second one shows the enemy's ACS
strain ACS strain builds up orange like
this whenever you attack and when the
bar fills fully the enemy's guard is
broken in this state of ACS overload
enemies take direct damage which means
any attack you unleash In This Moment is
far more damaging to the enemy's Health
naturally enemies can do impact damage
to you as well and your ACS strain will
build up here above your energy bar if
an enemy attack breaks your guard your
AC will pause like this and you'll take
additional damage as well to ensure that
this doesn't happen you should try and
maneuver for extended periods where you
don't take any damage after a few
seconds of no damage ACS strain will
diminish and this is where the
environment often comes in handy it's
something you can use to block attacks
giving you time to reduce ACS strain and
often to reload as well but notice how
my assault rifle isn't doing much impact
damage to this shielded enemy that's
because some weapons are better at
building up impacts than others if I use
my explosive missiles or my blade for
example then I can easily break the
guard of the target
the first true test of your skills will
be this the ah12 HC helicopter in this
fight you'll have to use everything
you've learned plus another skill as
well the quick boost by tapping square
or X you'll be able to dash for
additional avoidance it's worth noting
that in Almond core there are no
invincibility frames however so think of
quick boost as a way to quickly get
distance away from an enemy's attack
rather than an ability that you use to
dodge an enemy's attack quick boost is
particularly useful while Target assist
is enabled because your thumb is free to
tap the Boost button and I highly
recommend putting Target assist on while
you're fighting most boss battles
because it's here that you're going to
have to pay special attention to enemy
movements and attacks so to recap in
this fight I'm going to try and
accomplish a few things I'm going to use
Target assist to hard lock onto the
enemy and I'm going to constantly fire
my rifle and missiles pretty much as
soon as they're available I'm also going
to do my best to assault boost in and
use my blade on cooldown this is my main
damage dealer in this fight
I returned to the ground to recover
energy I'm going to do my best to stay
close to the enemy I'm safe when I'm
close and I'm safe when I'm underneath
the enemy but if the enemy has distance
on me I'm going to use the environment
to my advantage this is particularly
useful when you see warning signs like
this or if you just need a moment to
reload or repair or reposition
coming up with a battle plan for bosses
can really work wonders in this game so
with this I should just naturally come
out on top let's put this plan to the
test
check it out now
[Music]
after the mission is complete you'll
obtain your reward co-am credits minus
the ammunition and repair costs that
were incurred during your successful
Mission attempt after each Mission
you'll return to this the garage here
players can have some down time and
prepare for success in future missions
right now we've just finished mission
one and the parts shop isn't open to us
so let's check out the sortie menu
instead here you can and should do a few
things first head to the training
simulator here you can defeat some basic
enemies and learn some invaluable
lessons about the game if you ever need
to review these lessons then you can
always display the license menu in the
garage by pressing triangle or Y then
navigate down to the tips screen by
completing training you'll often be
rewarded with powerful new parts for
your AC so I highly recommend completing
new training missions as soon as they
become available and do your best to
read all the information as well if you
want to quickly test out any of these
new parts then you can press the right
bumper during assembly to initiate an AC
test or you can just head down into the
AC test area from your saute menu once
you're here press the pause button it's
in this menu that you can spawn a
variety of enemies to practice against
without having to worry about incurring
costs from going out on missions you can
also switch out Parts in assembly and
they'll appear here on your AC
immediately you can even restock your
ammunition and heal up if needed AC
testing is an incredible tool however in
many cases it might be beneficial for
you to just go out on actual missions
instead and test out your weapons in the
field for this purpose there's the
replay missions option if you're
confident in your abilities then by
replaying missions you stand to gain
additional credits or a higher rank as
well and what's more some missions have
optional object or parts within them so
go out there get some more practice earn
some more credits and see what you can
find but when you feel ready you can
sortee onto your next mission and
progress in the game oftentimes you'll
have a choice of mission and you might
want to read the mission descriptions
and evaluate how many credits are on
offer as well because you'll need those
credits soon enough because after
mission 2 the parts shop becomes
available
here you can buy new parts or sell your
old parts and as you complete more
missions new parts will quickly become
available in the shop your available
credits can be seen here the price of
Parts can be seen here and buying parts
will show you a reduction of your
available funds but the most important
takeaway is this don't be afraid of
buying new parts and experimenting here
it's absolutely essential that you get a
feel for different parts and most
importantly Parts can always be sold
back to the shop for the same price you
purchased them at so nothing is ever
really lost in this shopping process
soon we'll go over the process of
constructing an AC but first I want to
say that there's one more way to acquire
AC parts and that's through a process
called log hunt after Mission 3 you'll
be able to participate in this log hunt
program this means that every time you
defeat an enemy in a mission that is
marked with this Battle Log icon you'll
gain progress towards your next Hunter
Rank at which point all Minds will
reward you with new Parts Battle logs
can either be bronze silver gold or
platinum with each being worth more than
the last so keep a look out for these
markers in your missions and if you do
miss one consider replaying that mission
to claim it Battle Log status will be
shown in your replay Mission screen here
and here so if it ever says pending or
the icon is grayed out replay the
mission find that Battle Log and
complete the mission to claim it before
long you should start feeling a lot more
confident in your piloting for me this
happened Mission 5 which was a short
mission that required that I take out a
DA Fung student pilot this mission was
over fast it wasn't too hard and it
netted me a lot of credits so I replayed
this over and over for a while these
frantic AC fights are great practice so
if you're struggling I highly recommend
you replay this Mission challenge
yourself to destroy the enemy AC as
quickly as possible claim your credits
go out and buy a new part to test and
then go back in and take out the enemy
AC again
if you get an s-rank you are doing
really well in this Mission before long
you'll be feeling much more confident
with the flow of the game and after a
few more missions you'll have enough
credits to refine your AC into something
that you want to Pilot and that process
of refining a build is a huge part of
the joy in armored Core there's a
special sort of satisfaction that comes
with putting together builds to
perfectly suit your needs so let's head
into AC design and break down that
process
as we go through the process of AC
design remember you'll rarely find parts
that are objectively better than others
in every way instead parts are balanced
by being strong in some areas and weaker
in others if a stat is blue that means
that stat is an improvement over the
stat of the part that you currently have
equipped in that slot if it's red then
that stat is a downgrade it's up to you
to decide what stats you value the most
for your build and that's what makes
this build process so fun and personal
12 parts make up an AC's assembly four
unit parts four frame Parts three inner
parts and an expansion slot when you
arrive in the AC design screen you can
cycle through these 12 categories
horizontally with your left and right
bumpers and in the column below you'll
be able to select the specific part that
you'd like to equip from that category
each part has a name seen here a weapon
class like handgun or bazooka seen here
and a written description that tells you
a bit about the weapon descriptions are
often great at describing what's unique
about a weapon at a glance without you
needing to go deeper into stats to
figure it out for example this bazooka
description tells us that it deals heavy
impact damage and if we go back into the
part specs section we can confirm that
this number is in blue and has an
upwards Arrow signifying that this
weapon indeed does do a lot more impact
damage than the assault rifle we
currently have equipped what we
currently have equipped is actually all
the way down at the lower end of the
impact scale as shown by this little
gray marker these five specks are the
simplified specks of each part if you
want to look at each part's detailed
specs you can press triangle or Y for an
expanded list and if you need any help
figuring out what all these specs do
then you can press the help button
select contextual help and then cycle
through for a more detailed description
of each spec if this expanded stat
screen is overwhelming to you don't
worry too much beginners can absolutely
get by with just the simplified stat
screen so for now let's go back to that
simplified view almost all parts have
two specs in common they all have a
weight and they all have an En load the
combined weight and en load total of all
your currently equipped Parts can be
seen on the right here in a section that
shows your AC's combined spec total
again you can toggle an expanded view of
this if you like but the simplified
version is more than enough for now and
even then what you'll really want to
keep an eye on the most is your current
load and your current en load this
little gray marker shows what your
current load is at this red or blue bar
shows how the currently selected part
will affect your current load and the
gray marker with an arrow shows the
maximum load your AC can handle we'll
talk about weight limit a little bit
later but for now just remember that you
generally do not want to ever go beyond
this arrowed marker weight and enload
are the two limiting factors that help
to offset the strength of Parts if a
part is heavier with a high en load that
means the part will generally be more
powerful but it also means that it will
be more difficult for your AC to carry
it if a part is light with a low en load
then the part might be somewhat weaker
but your AC will more easily be able to
equip it the power and utility of each
part are expressed by the main specs
situated above their weight and enload
for weapons these specs are typically
attack power impact and total rounds
attack power determines the damage
dealing performance of each projectile
essentially it's how much damage you can
do to an enemy's health bar impact
determines the damage that you do to an
enemy's ACS strain the higher your
impact the more easily you'll be able to
stagger an enemy and open them up to
direct damage total rounds are simply
the total amount of ammunition that
you're bringing into a mission with that
weapon this can be relevant as if you
run out of ammunition you'll no longer
be able to fire the weapon instead the
depleted weapon will be purged from your
AC and you'll be forced to fight with
your fists instead which can still work
in addition to these specs weapon parts
also have some icons that tell you more
about the weapon at a glance for example
the fourth slot will tell you if this
weapon affects a particular part of the
enemy craft the Napalm launcher for
example can inflict a status effect that
will cause the enemy to be staggered
more easily the third icon represents
whether a weapon is single shot or
whether it needs to be reloaded or if it
doesn't need to be reloaded and will
overheat instead if a weapon can
overheat the progress towards overheat
can be seen accumulating here around
your lock-on if possible keep an eye on
this bar and space out your shots to
allow your weapon to cool this will
avoid putting your weapon into an
overheat state if a weapon is in an
overheat State then you can't fire it
and you just have to wait for it to cool
down
and the second icon corresponds to the
type of weapon seen up here as well and
the first icon tells you the damage type
of the weapon so there are three types
of damage that your weapons can deal in
armored Core 6. kinetic energy and
explosive first let's talk kinetic
damage this is damage done with physical
projectiles most common in weapons like
the assault rifle the machine gun or
shotguns kinetic weapons are typically
better at close or medium range they
typically fire quite fast and they
generally also have a higher Direct Hit
adjustment spec on average which means
they're a great option for dealing
damage while an enemy is staggered the
second type of damage is energy damage
this is further split into three more
types laser plasma and pulse laser
weapons fire straight blue beams plasma
weapons are purple and create an AOE
explosion on impact and pulse Weaponry
fire bubble beams that are great at
wearing down pulse defenses on average
though energy weapons fire slowly and
are typically better at long range with
high attack power but low impact so use
these to capitalize on an enemy's broken
guard don't always rely on them to break
it the third type of damage is explosive
damage typically dealt by Bazookas
grenades and missiles explosive
projectiles often deal the same amount
of damage regardless of range and often
create an AOE explosion to boot what's
more weapons with explosive damage have
high impact and attack power specs
however this is offset by slow firing
rates and a lot of recoil they're a
great tool to have for breaking open
enemy guards though and most builds are
well served by having at least one
explosive weapon equipped so those are
the three types of damage but naturally
there are three types of Defense as well
if you stuck on a boss or enemies
consider what their defensive stats or
weaknesses might be and experiment with
different types of weapons
before I move on from weapons I'd like
to mention melee weapons and pulse
Shields as well melee weapons can only
be equipped to the left arm slot and
pulse Shields can only be equipped to
the left back slot we've talked about
melee weapons already but note that they
have a main spec called consecutive hits
which lets you know how many times the
melee weapon can strike with repeated
Taps of L2 as for pulse Shields I
probably wouldn't recommend them for a
beginner as using them properly requires
quite a bit of timing and finesse
that said if you do want to equip one
note that their main specs are damage
mitigation impact dampening and
deployment range damage mitigation is
essentially the percentage of damage
that the shield will block while it's
active impact dampening is a mechanic
that determines your initial guard
window when shields are deployed there's
this little brief moment where you can
block more incoming damage so blocks
should be timed ideally to correspond
with incoming attacks but be aware that
this will overheat your Shield more
quickly so you can't just repeatedly tap
it too many times lastly deployment
range is a value that determines the
size of your Shield next we have the
four frame parts of the AC let's start
with the head head parts are unique in
that they determine the power and range
of your scan function but beyond that
their main specs are AP attitude
stability and system recovery AP are
your armor points your health basically
attitude stability contributes towards
the maximum amount of stagger damage
that you can absorb so a higher value
means it'll be harder for an enemy to
strain your attitude control system and
knock you off balance and finally system
recovery determines how fast you will
recover from status effects inflicted by
things like fire or electricity
next the core part this is the part that
will typically contribute the most AP
and attitude to your build it's also
typically the heaviest uniquely though
the core part also has a stat called
generator output adjust which is a value
that determines how effective your
generator part will be at fulfilling
your energy needs but we'll get into
energy and generators a little bit later
and then there are the arms arms give AP
of course but the unique specs determine
your arm load limits and your level of
firearm specialization arm load limits
can come into play when your arms are
carrying extremely heavy Weaponry if
you're holding weapons that are too
heavy you'll get this warning on the
right which means you'll need to equip
lighter Weaponry or choose arms with a
heavier load limit finally there's
firearm specialization which improves
Target tracking performance if you find
your shots are missing your target a lot
consider selecting arm parts that have
higher firearm specialization
finally and most importantly we have the
leg part and this might just be the most
important part in your AC's entire
assembly let me explain so leg Parts
contribute AP and attitude stability
like all your other frame Parts but
they're unique in that they are
responsible for carrying the combined
weight of everything else on your AC
thus their most defining spec is this
their load limit this value changes this
arrowed marker over here which
determines the maximum weight you can
carry and it's the marker that you never
want to exceed when building your AC
generally the closer you can get your AC
to this load limit the better though I
will point out that the further back you
go from this marker the lighter your AC
will be and it will grant a slight
increase to your Boost speed as a result
but the really unique thing about legs
is up here and that's their type there
are four types of Lake bipedal
reverse jointed quadruped legs and tank
treads each come in heavy or light
variants but it's the type of leg you
choose that plays a massive part in how
your AC will control
biped legs are your jack of all trades
they're certainly a safe bet for new
players and they're all you have access
to at the beginning of the game before
long though you'll unlock these reverse
joints reverse joints are still bipedal
legs but they're unique in that they
have unparalleled jumping abilities in
gameplay this means that your jump will
Propel you further into the air and it
also means that your quick boost will
fling you further to the side while
you're grounded consider reverse joints
if you need to be more Airborne or more
evasive but note that you'll generally
be more easy to knock off balance if
you're ever hit with these legs one of
the drawbacks to all bipedal Lakes is
that they don't absorb recoil whenever
you fire heavy Weaponry or burst
Weaponry notice how I'm pausing in the
air when I fire these sorts of weapons
that's because of my biped legs and
while it's absolutely still viable to
use weapons like these with biped legs
this pause can definitely get you
destroyed if you fire at the wrong
moment
however that recoil is not as impactful
with the other two classes of leg which
are quadruped and tank treads quadruped
and tank treads can absorb recoil from
heavy or burst Weaponry allowing you to
fire them while you're moving though
it's worth noting that quads do slow
down slightly while firing while tanks
are uninhibited completely
this ability to hover is what sets
quadrupeds apart from tank threads once
you're Airborne all you need to do is
press the jump button again with X or a
to hover in the air pressing jump a
third time will drop you out of this
mode while you're in it you can still
Dodge and fire your Weaponry though you
are slow and you'll need to return to
the ground to make substantial energy
gains the biggest advantage of flying
like this is for maintaining additional
range from enemies and just in the fact
that it often gives you a straight line
of sight at enemies without any
environmental clutter getting in your
way it's also amazing against certain
enemies that don't have attacks that can
reach you so consider keeping a set of
quadruped legs on hand in case you need
them they can be a really powerful
situational tool to have at your
disposal thanks to their hover ability
with tank treads on the other hand your
booster part is actually removed from
your AC assembly entirely as the tank
treads come with their own inbuilt
boosters with some exceptions flight
isn't typically a strong point of most
tank treads tank treads are more about
grounded movement and operating these
really feels like driving a wheeled
vehicle where the direction you're
facing really matters that said you can
still quick boost while grounded which
will instantly change your direction if
needed and Propel you into a temporary
drift State slower Treads will also
benefit from making frequent use of the
assault boost ability to cover distance
at the end of the day though tank treads
are really designed to carry an enormous
load and it's generally a good idea to
load your tank with the most devastating
weaponry and the most resilient frame
Parts you can carry the next three parts
of your AC are its inside parts
consists of the booster the FCS and the
generator booster parts are most defined
by their thrust there upward thrust and
their quick boost thrust specs your
basic thrust value is what determines
your default speed while gliding and
flying an AC with a high default speed
will naturally be quite avoidant without
you needing to take any particularly
evasive maneuvers which you might
consider useful if you want to focus on
things other than dodging your upward
thrust is exactly what it sounds like
this value determines how powerful your
upward trajectory will be being in the
air can help you to avoid explosions on
the ground and it also allows you to get
a better angle on your enemies so
consider this spec especially relevant
for certain encounters and then there's
your quick boost thrust which determines
how fast your thrust will be when your
quick boost is activated this expanded
view actually shows a lot more quick
boost values that you should also
consider but generally you should only
select for quick boost thrust if you
find yourself facing an enemy that you
think requires a lot of manual dodging
another important stat is hidden in the
expanded stat screen and that's quick
boost reload ideal weight spec if your
total weight rises above this value your
AC will have its quick boost reload time
progressively penalized quick boosts and
flight require energy so naturally we
should talk about the generator next
because it's this part that determines
the nature of your energy bar a
generator's main specs are its en
capacity its en recharge and its Supply
recovery en capacity simply determines
the maximum amount of energy in your
energy bar an AC with a higher en
capacity will be able to perform more
actions before this R is depleted
however it's also important to take into
account your en recharge rate as this
determines how quickly your energy will
recover an AC with a high recharge rate
will be able to spend less time
recovering and more time doing actions
the then there's Supply recovery which
determines how quickly your generator
will recover if you fully deplete your
energy bar ideally you'll never fully
deplete your energy bar but sometimes
that's necessary to avoid attacks and
high Supply recovery will get you back
to the action without being punished too
hard
finally unlike every other part the
generator doesn't actually have an En
load it has an En output so it's the
generator that's responsible for
supporting the en load of the rest of
your system your total en load can be
seen here on the right and the gray
marker represents the combined en load
of all your currently equipped parts
that red or blue bar determines how that
en load will change depending on the
part you have selected and the arrowed
marker is your maximum en capacity as
defined by your generators en output
stat basically if you're exceeding your
maximum en load you'll see red here and
that means you either need to switch to
more energy efficient parts or choose a
generator with a higher en output the
last part we need to go over is the FCS
part which is the biggest contributor to
your aiming accuracy you might have
noticed when you lock onto enemies your
aim is actually determined by this
little reticle within the lock-on when
it's red you're considered in range and
your non-homing projectiles should hit
their mark key word there though is
should because this Little Radical isn't
always on point sometimes it will waver
sometimes it will lag behind and it's
this behavior that is determined by the
FCS part FCS Parts have three main specs
they're close range assist medium range
assist and long range assist close range
assist determines how good your reticle
will be at tracking enemies within the
130 meter range medium range determines
how good tracking will be between 130
and 260 meters and long range determines
how good tracking will be Beyond 260
meters pay special attention to distance
markers during combat and try to stay
within the optimal range for your FCS
and your weapon
missile tracking is separate from the
FCS but the FCS does determine how fast
you can acquire a missile lock and how
fast your multi-lock capabilities are so
this is a factor to consider for your
build
and that's the basics of everything in
your assembly and if it sounds like a
lot well you're not wrong but rest
assured that it will start to make sense
as you jump in and experiment with
things so let's try and put together a
unique build now and while yours might
be different from this build I'll show
you the order that I generally prefer to
put things together
one of the most straightforward ways to
get started with a build is to First
decide on which FCS part you should use
that's because this forces you to decide
early whether you want to build
something for close medium or long range
or whether you want something that's
just decent at every range having an
idea in mind helps when getting started
so let's aim for a close range build and
choose a close range part the FCS I want
to go for is this the FCS G2 Dash P10
SLT it has good performance at close to
medium range and it comes with the added
benefit of quick missile lock time which
is great as we'll be using missiles as
well so next let's choose a good close
range arm weapon to suit our FCS expand
its back screens reveal optimal ranges
for firing each weapon and the one for
the mg-014 Ludlow reveals that it's a
great great close range option so let's
equip two of them one for each arm what
we're using now is called a double
trigger build meaning you'll be dual
firing these machine guns at once with
both of your triggers the ludlow's
description also specifically calls out
that it's great in dual trigger builds
this is why reading descriptions can be
so useful as mentioned before the
description on our FCS revealed that
it's principally designed to reduce
missile lock time which means that our
missiles will also be a very effective
tool so let's equip two sets of those on
our back and all of a sudden we have a
build that is deadly at close range and
with long range missiles as well looking
good the next decision I like to make is
legs you have to ask what would suit a
close range build well you could go
light and avoid taking damage entirely
but as a beginner you're probably going
to get hit a lot anyway so might as well
go with something heavy for now let's go
with the Tian Chung bipedal legs as
these give us a high load limit to play
with while we select our other parts
having a high load limit makes it so
much easier to put together an AC I can
confidently select heavier parts now and
by intentionally selecting four heavy
weights I can kind of just trust that
the other specs will naturally be quite
good another way to quickly put together
a build is to buy parts that just exist
within a family of Parts most parts will
have keywords like VP or Malanda as well
as a company logo that can help you
ascertain the family of parts that they
exist within for example buying all of
Schneider's knocked Raya parts will make
your build very fast and great in the
air whereas buying all of Da Fung's Tian
Chung parts will naturally make you
slower but very tanky so by buying all
of the parts in a family you can easily
get a good idea of the type of AC those
parts are moving you towards and while
you're definitely encouraged to mix and
match buying all the parts in the family
is kind of a guarantee that they'll work
well together which might be a welcoming
thing to many beginners
because I've replayed Mission 5 so many
times I have over a million credits so
I'm going to use these to buy every
frame part in da Fung's heavyweight
family of Parts if you don't have enough
credits here consider replaying missions
or selling parts that you don't need and
if you can't afford the same parts that
I'm buying don't worry consider parts to
be a goal to work towards and just see
if you can get by in the meantime next
let's choose boosters manually dodging
with your quick boost can be a lot of
extra input for a beginner so let's just
select for a high thrust stat instead
this will enable us to move at a high
speed by default and we should just
naturally avoid a lot of attacks this
way luckily the BST G2 po4 is perfect
for those needs next I like to choose a
generator now generators can get pretty
heavy but since we have those High load
bearing legs we might as well just
choose the heaviest generator we can
find this generator the Ling tie gives
us a reduction in our en capacity but
notice it's only a slight reduction
considering the dramatic increase in our
en recharge and Supply recovery I'd say
this is a very welcome trade-off
so in the end you should have something
like this a close range AC with an
extremely high AP and defensive
performance but we're not done because
once you have a build you should take a
moment to review things the most
important thing to look at is your
current load a good goal is to try and
get as close to your weight limit as
possible without exceeding it so if you
have a ton of space free at this final
stage it means you might want to go back
and put on some heavier parts
alternatively if you're nowhere near
your load limit you might want to go
back to your leg selection and choose
lighter load-bearing legs as that would
confer benefits by bringing you closer
to your weight limit all that said don't
worry too much about being super close
to your weight limit even though I have
some space here I'm happy with that too
because space means I'll be able to
quickly switch to heavier weapons if the
mission requires it without changing any
of my other parts which is really
convenient
speaking of weight consider expanding
the stat screen on your booster here and
check that your total weight doesn't
exceed your ideal weight spec on your
booster by too much again the more you
exceed this value the slower you'll be
able to Quick boost repeatedly
last check your AC's maximum en load
like with weight it's important to be
under and as close to your ideal en load
as possible if you feel like you've
settled into a really optimal build then
it's often a great idea to head into the
AC data screen here you can name your AC
and save this build for future use this
is a great way to get some personal
attachment to the build that you're
using and also in a practical sense
having multiple Builds on hand can help
you to quickly adapt to different
situations you can also try and copy
enemy AC presets over in this tab as
long as you have all their parts
available
finally consider stockpiling a few
backup Parts before you go out into
missions this will allow you to switch
up your assembly Mid Mission which can
be extremely useful me personally I'm
going to buy two Bazookas because you
never know when you might need a bazooka
or two the first mission that new
players are kind of likely to get stuck
on is this operation War climber so I'm
going to use this mission to show off a
few more advanced mechanics our first
objective is to take out the Gatling
guns over here now while objective
markers show you your goal you don't
always have to take the straight route
to get there for example if we go
straight there we'll have to go through
a battlefield and straight into Gatling
gunfire which is not the best idea so
instead since our build is a little bit
on the slower side let's take the scenic
route the tank is still shooting us but
by listening for warning signs and
staying in the air to avoid explosions
on the ground we can reduce the damage
taken here
[Music]
next we go over the rampots firing our
Weaponry on the way assault boost Keeps
Us fast enough and tanky enough to avoid
the snipers aiming at us and by tapping
Ascend to end my assault boost I can
maintain momentum and quickly regain
energy on the ground
thank you
by setting up a flanking run I can take
out the Gatling guns without having to
stop
next listen for warning sounds as you go
through the city these will basically
tell you when you're at risk of getting
hit we can use the environment for cover
and even use our Compass at the bottom
here to locate any nearby enemies there
are quite a few enemy MTS in the city
but directional markers will let you
know where an enemy has fired at you
from
this marker lets me know that there's
one coming up right behind me
repair kits heal a flat 4000 AP you
should always try to use them after
you've taken 4000 damage to make sure
you get the full benefit from it but
it's also valuable to stay topped up so
you don't have to heal in the middle of
a fight instead
our next objective is the Baus tetrapod
it's hidden in a nook under the city
let's get to it
there's the tetrapod and because it's a
single imposing enemy it's probably a
good idea to toggle on our Target lock
with R3 before we get started when
fighting enemies it's important to keep
in mind your weapon's effective range
this is something that you should try
and memorize in the garage before
heading into battle our weapons
effective range is 236 meters so we
should look at the distance marker and
try to keep that in mind
now normally our weapon would be
effective at this range but against this
enemy it's not that's because this enemy
has very high defense therefore our
weapon is Ricochet at range remember to
keep an eye out for this Ricochet
notification while you play if it
appears it means you'll do little to no
damage unless you get within your ideal
range at which point attack power is
guaranteed without ricochets for this
weapon our ideal range is 115 meters
because my AC is slow and my Weaponry is
good in short bursts I'm going to use
the environment to my advantage here by
peeking around this corner whenever my
missiles are up I can build up ACS
strain at range with no risk and when
the enemy comes close to me that's great
because my machine guns can take it to
ACS Breaking Point without it posing any
threat when playing consider your build
strengths and consider the enemy's
weaknesses and come up with a plan if
that plan doesn't work reassess your
build or reassess your strategy that's
how you overcome difficulty in armored
Core
see the bottom right that's where you'll
be able to note that you've unlocked a
checkpoint we're done here and we can
proceed but while we're here we might as
well take out the Cannons that were
pestering us on the wall these are
optional enemies but every kill rewards
us with credits in the bottom right
therefore destroying these cannons is
well worth it if we have the time
our objective marker tells us where to
go now but there are often other ways to
your objective as well for example if we
take this door above our objective
marker we can actually sneak inside and
get an advantageous High position over
our enemies there's a marker here that
denotes that they're unaware of us right
now damage dealt to these enemies during
this time will result in higher impact
and ACS strain
the final boss of this mission is a
tough one it's the Juggernaut the
Juggernaut has armor that negates all
damage from the front note the armor
notification here however its sides back
and top are vulnerable so a build that
has great generator capacity and high
booster thrust speed will be able to
maneuver in the air and get over the
Juggernaut more effectively any build
can beat the Juggernaut but if you're
using a build that has to return to the
ground more often then you might have a
harder time but if you fail during this
Mission don't worry the game's
checkpoint system will instantly allow
you to restart at difficult encounters
what's more if you have the parts then
you can consider quickly switching up
your build here by entering assembly
remember how I said my build has some
extra load free well I'm gonna make use
of that now and I'm going to equip two
heavy Bazookas instead of my machine
guns these Bazookas deal explosive
damage which will help me to stagger the
Juggernaut much more effectively the
Juggernaut is a slow large Target so the
usual drawbacks of using Bazookas don't
really come into play here another thing
to consider during this fight is whether
you want to use Target assist with R3 or
not it's true that yes Target assist is
generally great if we're just facing One
Singular enemy but there are absolutely
exceptions to this rule the Juggernaut
is one of them Target assist has a few
drawbacks in this fight for one it
forces you to move at an angle
respective to the enemy this is
especially concerning if I try to
assault boost towards the Juggernaut
doing this while locked on means I'm
assault boosting right into its front
that's not where I want to go with
Target lock disabled we're able to move
more freely around the enemy what's more
our assault boost is free to be aimed
above or beside the Juggernaut better
enabling us to get around it as an added
incentive playing without Target lock
actually increases the tracking strength
of your lock-on so our shots will find
their target more often if we don't use
Target assist consider all of these
things and your overall skill level when
considering whether to use Target lock
in your missions
shortly after operation wall climber two
new menus will become available the
arena and Os tuning the arena is a
ranked simulator where you can fight
enemy AC there's no healing or multiple
enemies just a fair one-on-one fight
here you can climb in the ranks and
while we can only fight against F rank
opponents at this early stage of the
game more enemies will be unlocked as
you progress in your missions and the
arena is absolutely something you should
be clearing as soon as new AC fights
become available not only is this
invaluable practice for some of the
hardest fights in the game not only are
you rewarded with credits with no repair
or ammunition costs the most important
thing is that you're also rewarded with
a crucial resource OST chips OST chips
are a resource that can be spent on
various categorical upgrades for your AC
this is done in the OS tuning menu and
once you're here you'll be met with a
series of upgrades some of the upgrades
in these menus are intended for more
experienced players for example few
players will ever find they need to aim
manually or to enter a mission while
overburdened so be careful not to waste
your points on upgrades that you won't
use that said you can recover your spent
OST chips by pressing triangle or Y this
will cost you 4 000 credits for every OS
upgrade you need to undo
with some upgrades here will make any
player stronger regardless of their
skill level while I'd recommend you read
through and consider these yourself
let's go through each category now and
pick out a few priorities in terms of
system unlocks one that I'd absolutely
recommend everyone unlock eventually is
the kick function with this enabled
you'll be able to do a melee Slam at the
end of your assault boost by pressing L3
once again this is especially great
while you're hard locked onto an enemy
with Target assist and it's the perfect
Capstone to an enemy who is almost guard
broken because it saves you having to
expend ammunition on breaking their
guard and it leaves your ammunition free
to capitalize on their broken guard
instead next let's talk expansions once
unlocked expansions can be slotted into
your AC's assembly and while you can
only equip one expansion at a time you
can invest into unlocking multiple
charges of each expansion however note
that unlocking multiple expansion
charges is expensive and there's a cool
down period after using an expansion
charge
by default expansions are activated by
pressing L3 and triangle or Y
simultaneously however you can switch
these controls in the game settings here
personally I prefer type B which allows
activation with L3 and R3 which is easy
to remember when you're just starting
out it is easy to forget to use your
expansions so if you're new to the game
then I'd actually recommend that you
choose a passive expansion instead for
example this is terminal armor once
equipped it's always active and will
always keep you alive at 1 AP for a few
more seconds in a situation where you
would have been destroyed this can give
you valuable time to heal or just
survive a little longer I really can't
overstate how useful passive upgrades
are in an input heavy game like armored
Core 6. after terminal armor I'd
recommend getting the early ranks of
many passive upgrades you can't go too
wrong here and by investing in passive
upgrades you can rest assured that your
AC is becoming more powerful
and that concludes the guide thank you
for watching for more tips lore and
secrets about armored Core 6 consider
subscribing to my channel and other than
that good luck everybody get to work